вітаємо вас це програма У фокусі Європи
я Лара баба Лола раді що ви з нами
Британія готується до Коронації короля
Чарльза який став монархом після смерті
своєї матері королеви Єлизавети другої
ця подія до якої чари зготувався все
своє життя і ставки високі як для короля
так і для його дружини Каміли серія
скандалів у публічних сварок поставила
королівську родину підпільну увагу тепер
король опинився під тиском Адже від
нього залежить майбутнє монархії та
Сполученого Королівства
ця корона центральний елемент Коронації
символ монархії вона виготовлена з
чистого золота і прикрашена сотнями
дорогоцінних каменів і перлин для одних
Вона сліпучо прекрасна але для інших Це
видовище яке вони не хотіли б бачити
британська республіканці зокрема Бен
Клінтон хочуть повністю скасувати
монархію це намислимо для прихильників
королівської сім'ї які зараз планують
свої коронаційні заходи для них це шанс
увійти і в історію і це перша така
церемонія за останні 70 років
вступ до нової ери Коронація короля
Чарльза
святкових заходів багато і не лише перед
букінгемським палацом по всій країні
піддані корони готуються до зустрічі
свого нового короля
вулиця боевиллі роуд у мейденхеді
невеликому містечку на півдні Великої
Британії не виняток
королева була чудовим прикладом Я думаю
що Чарльз буде не гіршим
на честь Великого дня мешканці
перекривають усю вулицю організатори
вечірки мають багато роботи
[музика]
це дуже велике свято і ми чекаємо на
нього з нетерпінням
Але не всі британці сповнені ентузіазму
республіканці bentle Клінтон і Девід
маккальпен налаштовані рішуче вони
кажуть що вже давно Настав час для змін
чому ми не повинні мати можливість самі
обирати главу держави Чому ми маємо
миритися з сім'єю яку не обрали з тим що
ніхто не може претендувати на посаду
глави держави в цій країні а жодна
молода людина не може підняти голови
сказати Я хочу це зробити я хочу
поставити собі мету покращити життя
людей це суперечить усім демократичним
нормам і не лише це республіканці
стверджують що монархія дорого
обходиться розслідування проведене
британської газетою оцінило особисті
статки короля майже у 2 мільярди фунтів
стерлінгів навряд чи це прийнятно у часи
коли деякі британці ледве можуть
прогодувати свої сім'ї кажуть вони
мілорди прошу сідати
[музика]
ці величезні привілеї не зароблене
багатство і статус зміцнює всю класову
систему
класу в цій країні і це серйозна
проблема
ніхто не може по-справжньому дістатися
вершини
Чарльз 3 на відміну від своєї покійної
матері викликає протести своїми
публічними виступами Але незважаючи на
яйця що летять у його бік Він здається
не зважає на негативну увагу незворушно
проходячи повз демонстрації
як ця на півночі Англії її гасло не мій
король
згідно з опитуваннями молоді британці
все більш скептично ставляться до
королівської сім'ї
Ми сподіваємося що завдяки цим
коронаційним протестам ми дійсно
Виростимо Ми сподіваємося зростати
проливати світло на деякі дуже
несправедливі речі які Королівська сім'я
робила протягом останніх кількох
десятиліть а не лише за останній рік Я
гадаю що це дає нам чудову можливість
донести наше послання світові
Але у бо інвеліровуд послання
республіканців залишилося не почути діти
розмальовують королівську карету чи
подібні королівські атрибути а дорослі
готуються до святкувань
Чума записати скони що подавати до після
обіднього чаю де розвішувати прапори
організатори вечірки сходяться на думці
74-річний Чарльз ідеальний голова
держави
він розуміє проблеми які стоять перед
країною і розуміє сильні сторони які
вона має
Отже Британія завжди була монархією це
історія це частина структури Сполученого
Королівства відмова від неї була б
згубною для країни
Якби він пішов у відставку і монархія
припинила своє існування це могло б
викликати резонанс по всьому світу
Чарльз Каміла і королівська родина досі
популярні у Британії а їхня королівська
пишність викликає велике захоплення вони
продовжать представляти країну на
міжнародному рівні
принаймні поки що адже молодим британцям
стає все складніше жити У рамках
традицій багато вікової форми правління
і монархії
[музика]
для фермерів Настав час посівної і
грунтообробні машини перекопують поля Що
підготувати ґрунт але в Україні одній з
найбільших у світі країн-виробників
зерна а ірація землі супроводжується
великими ризиком Олег Гірман боїться за
своє життя коли ступає на свої поля
на східному фронті України тривають бої
проти в районі Харкова українські
війська змогли відтіснити російські сили
і отримати територію
перетворили багато полів на смертельні
пастки для українських фермерів
зараз коли прийшла весна Олег Гірман мав
би обробляти свої поля але він не може
хоч російські війська і пішли з
Харківської області Але вони залишили
вибухонебезпечні сувеніри українським
фермерам
ось це їхні позиції були тому попереду
себе Вони все мінували і це якраз мої
всі поля що на ось цих крайніх полях
можна лише здогадуватися
орати цю землю і засівати її важкими
сівалками для Олега германа було просто
самогубством на мій погляд це
протитанкова Міна лежала вона ось тут
поруч А ту мабуть була з яким сюрпризом
після запеклих боїв що точилися в
Харківській області ця місцевість
вважається на 100% заповненої мінами та
снарями що не розірвалися
і знайти їх не важко це один кінець
російської ракети Смерч
тут знаходиться двигун ніхто не знає що
може бути тут під землею Олег Герман
бачить що під загрозою опинилося все
його існування до початку війни у нього
працювало 30 робітників відтоді за його
словами Він втратив півмільйона євро
Він один із тисяч фермерів яких спіткала
така ж доля в Україні коли свідомі як
життниця Європи
було дуже боляче
і потім коли спілкувався зі своїми
колегами
У деяких розбив ферму
Вважайте що Україна має найвищу
щільність наземних мін серед усіх країн
світу
національні та міжнародні організації
такі як британська халат раз працюють на
місцях намагаючись знешкодити і прибрати
міни
проти піхотні міни з натискними
пластинами проти піхотні осколкові міни
гранати на розтяжках
знаходимо всі види касетних боєприпасів
які використовуються в Україні проти
транспортні міни у пластикових і
металевих корпусах
експерти кажуть що від 30 до 40% всієї
території України доведеться розмінувати
перш ніж її відкриють для громадськості
У нас є люди які не можуть ходити по
своїй землі по своєму подвір'ю виїхати
на пікнік вільно гуляти через зміни
водночас вони не можуть обробляти свою
землю що у більшості випадків основне
джерело доходу для сім'ї
крім того є також інфраструктурні зони
які були заміновано
ми бачимо як в Україні зростає кількість
нещасних випадків
але багато фермерів змушені ризикувати
щоб вижити у деяких регіонах вони
ризикують власним життям обробляючи
землю
сюди і сюди Ну тут більше Нормально Тут
же так нормально
а тут ще довго буде зживати там ось така
рвана рана
металевих осколків мало в основному
пластиці гума
зараз нормально але вперше він було
зовсім не весело
Юрій наїхав на міну на своєму тракторі
йому дивом вдалося залишитися живим
проте він не збирається здаватися навіть
якщо йому доведеться розміновувати Ніни
власноруч Він показує нам військову
амуніцію яку знайшов у полі
Ну я ж перший
Наскільки я знаю по Україні Я не перший
і не останній це 100%
відірвався
Олег єрман також думає над тим щоб
самому розмінувати свої поля щоб
зберегти своє господарство
Я дуже сподіваюсь що нам допоможуть Ну
якщо не допоможуть і це вже буде другий
рік це вже і люди не можуть працювати І
вони не отримують коштів ми розуміємо
хтось виїжджає хтось вже не повернеться
тобто
восстанавлювати буде це дуже важко Якщо
це не зробити зараз
він непокоїться що цей аграрний сезон
може стати вирішальним для нього та його
господарства
Швеція відома своєю позицією політично
нейтральної держави але вторгнення Росії
в Україну змусило диких шведів
переглянути цю багаторічну політику
тепер Північний європейці порушують
статус-кво і шукають захисту в НАТО
оборонному Союзі європейських та
північноамериканських країн
як найшвидшого вступу до Альянсу через
своє сусідство з Росією Стокгольм
нещодавно вислав кількох російських
дипломатів Через імовірно загрозу
державній безпеці стосунки між двома
країнами погіршуються
таких молодих солдатів як Філіпа війна в
Україні змінила все і військові навчання
набули нової актуальності та важливості
багато наречених хочуть виділитися у
день свого весілля але такий образ як
цей дійсно унікальний для Європи
Наречена кадуре бере участь у
багатовіковій традиції вона належить до
мусульманської меншини по маті ця
етнічна меншина зуміла зберегти свою
культуру незважаючи на період утисків за
часів комуністичного режиму Болгарії
наша кореспондентка побувала на весіллі
у південних болгарських родопах там у
віддаленому селі Рибному На власні очі
вона побачила святкування не схоже на
жодне інше
Це особливий момент для 20-річної кадури
Audi
разом зі своїми сестрами кузинами та
молодими подругами вона прибуває на
центральну площу гірського села рибного
[музика]
вона помок болгарська мусульманка
спочатку дівчина танцює сама для
односельців а потім зі своїм нареченим і
суфом мусанковим
[музика]
два з половиною дні триватиме їхні
весільна церемонія низка традиційних
обрядів гостини танців
[оплески]
ребнова розташований високо в горах
родопи на південному заході Болгарії
дорога з долини була прокладена лише в
1970-х роках
за часів комуністичного режиму у
Болгарії рибного мало репутацію осередку
повстанців
суботній ранок перший день весілля
друзі та родичі вішають на дерев'яну
раму придане наречений серед речей
ковдри покривала та червоні панталони їх
вивішують на загальний огляд
дідусь Мехмед задоволений
кадури друга з його онучок Яка вийшла
заміж
сам Мехмед одружився таємно близько 50
років тому бокомуністичний уряд
забороняв мусульманське весілля
у Мехмеда навіть не залишилося жодної
фотографії із власного весілля
у нас було кілька фотографій Але після
1970 року Все змінилося
вдиралися в домівки людей
вони рвали жіночі панталони хустки
чоловічі кашкети і всі фотографії просто
рвали їх на шматки
які багато інших Мехмед був змушений
змінити ім'я на слов'янську болгарське
минуле облав я нічого не підписував але
це було моїм ім'ям протягом 20 років і
так само було з іменами моїх дітей
неділя другий день весілля
весільна процесія рухається селом
святкування набирає обертів молодяту
віщують грошима вийшло все село
жителі рибного пишаються своєю культурою
їхні традиційні весільні звичаї
унікальні тому вони подали заяву до
Юнеско на визнання їх не матеріальної
світової спадщиною
для нас Важливо щоб весільні традиції
народу рибного були визнані не
матеріальною світовою спадщиною Болгарії
і стали частиною списку Юнеско щоб ми
могли бути такими ж видами як і різні
інші етнічні громади у Болгарії
у домі батьків нареченої починається
ритуал геліни
він означає чистоту і повний початок
наречену старанної майстерно гримують
кажуть що цей ритуал походить із
прадавніх часів
перед будинком збирається все більше
людей які чекають на появу нареченої
перетворення нареченої на галіну триває
півтори години
[музика]
тепер вона може показатися перед усіма
присутніми із заплющеними очима як того
вимагає традиція
[музика]
для помахів з рибного це один із проявів
того наскільки життєво важливою
залишається їхня культура яка довгий час
була пригніченою
[музика]
Круасан і багети два найпопулярніших
продукти французького кулінарного
експорту сучасні пекарів досконалюють
традиційні рецепти додають нові
інгредієнти до цих основних продуктів
але для декого Це просто не мислимо
органічні пекарі такі як максим-бусі
обрали туристичний підхід за принципом
менше значить краще і для цього вони
повернули час на сотні років назад
Максим бусі почувається найщасливішим
коли замішує своє тісто
лише з борошна води та солі
я роблю все за інстинктом
у його крихітні пекарні у центрі Парижа
майже немає техніки
тут планує ремесло які за часів його
діда
в усі пурист і шанує вікові французькі
традиції випіканні у своїй буланжері
навіть інструменти 41-річного майстра
ручної роботи
я змайстрував цю ємність для замішування
тіста нещодавно
Я встановив її на масажний стіл щоб
можна було регулювати висоту
французи славляться своєю випічкою
круасанами з маслом шоколадом і звісно
багетами але в усі цурається всього
цього Вони занадто складні і містять
хімічні добавки
усе що виходить із його печі справжній
хліб
треба було витягти їх раніше бо вони
трохи підсохли
справжні кисле тісто велика рідкість у
Франції але воно дуже смачне з гордістю
каже в усі і не викликає алергій
І це ще не все такі пекарі як він хочуть
повернутися до способу життя У єднанні з
природою і з усіма тими з ким він працює
часто в ремеслах ланки ланцюга - це люди
із ними рушника і фермер який вирощує
пшеницю
у наших інтересах розвивати ці локальні
канали і заново відкривати для себе
справжній смак речей
це живить нас так само як і хліб
у Парижі пекарні подібні до пекарні бусі
досі новинка
але за межами столиці є пекарі які
займаються своїм ремеслом на що більш
низовому рівні
Бенджамін пелетьє вирощує власну пшеницю
для свого хліба
тут все живе це все залишки рослин
якість понадкістю його девіз
Ідея полягала в тому що відродити сорти
які вирощували до Другої світової війни
запропонувати щось інше альтернативу
всім сучасним сортам які ми маємо
сьогодні
у своєму господарстві пекар не лише
вирощує але й мелеп пшеницю
відомі як селянські пекарі вони
складають незначну меншість із приблизно
35 000 пекарів у Франції але їхні
старовинні методи стають дедалі
популярнішими
кам'яні жорна
наші методи дуже прості зерно
перемелюється з одного операцію
у промислових монах борошно проходить
через жорна 12-13 разів
у нас воно грубе і дуже просте
селянські пекарі виступають за
автентичність і якість життя саме тому
пекарня бусі відкрити лише 4 години
щодня
покупці по сусідству зацікавлені вони
заінтриговані концепцією А як їм хліб
селянський пекарбусі не прагне
розбагатіти Він більш ніж задоволений
своїм ремеслом і своїм життям
дехто каже що замішування тіста це форма
медитацій А ми на цьому завершуємо
випуску фокусі Європи до наступної
зустрічі до побачення
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив Київ 2023 рік
[музика]